welcome back to law and crime daily
we're moving now to Marion County
Florida on Tuesday authorities announced
an arrest in the fatal shooting of a
woman during a neighbor dispute police
were already responding to a trespassing
call at an apartment complex on Friday
when a shooting was reported at the same
location authorities found 35 year old
AJ Owens in front of the suspect's
apartment with a gunshot wound she was
taken to a hospital and pronounced dead
the suspect has been identified as 58
year old Susan Lawrence investigators
believe that she got mad at her Owen's
children who played in a field close to
her property evidence allegedly shows
that the suspect confronting the
children and even throwing things at
them the children told their mother and
she went to confront Lowrance that's
when police believe Lowrance shot one
bullet through her front door striking
Owens in the upper chest while two of
her children Stood Beside her Lowrance
told investigators she acted in
self-defense claiming that Owens tried
to break down her door she also accused
Owens of attacking her in the past
loran's face says charges of
manslaughter negligence assault and
battery her first court appearance is
scheduled for Thursday morning
many people were wondering why it took
authorities four days to make an arrest
despite surveillance cameras covering
most of the complex the police
department released the video late
Tuesday explaining why
sometimes when we do these
investigations of cases of this level
rushing into making arrest is not the
right thing to do sometimes
in fact
it could probably cause complications or
cause errors because we want to ensure
that what we present
that justice has served all the way
through the courts
and that the individual gets what they
deserve
and that's one of the things my
detectives cannot complete an
investigation without getting all sides
of a story
and that night all we had was one
person's story and that was the shooter
story
but miss owens's story had to be told
through evidence
and the eyes of witnesses who were there
I told you that we want nothing more
than Justice and this can only be
accomplished by maintaining the
Integrity of the case and leaving no
stone unturned
Josh the sheriff said that Florida stand
your ground law doesn't apply her so
could it still be considered by the
court system as charges move forward
well it's going to be considered in her
case in the way that she defends herself
and just helping jurors to understand
what uh she was experiencing that day
and and I mean don't get me wrong I
think this is an incredibly difficult
case for the defense and I think they
have a real uphill battle but if they're
going to mount any defense whatsoever
they're going to have to explain to
jurors what took place in that moment
what was it about the immediacy threat
that she felt that she was experiencing
in that moment that she felt that she
had to use deadly force the prosecution
on the other hand is going to
concentrate on the history between these
people on this ongoing feud on how this
wasn't about a moment this was about a
boiling anger and resentment growing
inside of her and that's what led her to
make this decision that day and
therefore it is not self-defense and
you know Florida has these laws that are
pretty strongly in favor of uh
self-defense but shooting through a door
seems like a really difficult argument
to me yeah the arguments you're saying
the defense has to make it almost sounds
like the defendant has to testify we'll
wait for that Terry what is your opinion
of the criminal charges brought against
the shooter do you think she should also
be charged with murder absolutely I do
because if you think about it this
wasn't manslaughter I think they have
charges for first degree murder actually
because for Florida all you have to do
is show that it's premeditated now many
people do think premeditated means it
has to be planned out weeks ahead months
ahead no premeditated can be at that
moment she decided I'm going to kill the
person at my door and she had no reason
to do that she didn't really see a
threat I mean it's a mother and a child
so and I also think second degree which
is a depraved mind so you know she had a
reckless disregard for any life so I
definitely think they could have put
murder charges and I think they could
have proven murder charges yeah what
you're saying Terry makes me have a
question of when did she decide to get
the gun I think that's going to be a big
point is here what level of
premeditation she had well when we come
back after just a few hours of
deliberation there's a verdict in the
trial of a former NFL player his team's
reaction from outside the courthouse is
next
foreign
[Music]
came in Wednesday afternoon in the
murder trial of former professional
football player Travis Rudolph it all
started when Rudolph got into a fight
with his now ex-girlfriend she texted
her brother to confront Rudolph with his
friends after the group of men showed up
to Rudolph's home a bra broke out
Rudolph eventually shot and killed 21
year old Sebastian Jean-Jacques and
prosecutors charge him with premeditated
murder the state argued that the men
were retreating during the gunfire what
Rudolph maintained that his actions were
in self-defense and several of his
family members agreed during their
testimony here's what the jury decided
in less than four hours
State of Florida versus Travis Rudolph
defendant verted we the jury find as
follows as to count one we find a
defendant not guilty as to count two we
finally defendant not good for me that's
the count three we find the defendant
not guilty as to count four we find the
defendant
not guilty so say we all the seventh day
of June 2023 in West Palm Beach Palm
Beach County Florida
surely after the verdict traffic was
Rudolph and his attorney spoke to
reporters about the case here's what
they had to say
what does this verdict mean to you it
means everything man I finally got my
freedom back to get back to my life
it means a lot for the support with
everyone what do you think of the fact
that they came back for the verdict that
just uh what three or four hours right
[Music]
it felt like it was right all alone
well you know life we're all human we
all make mistakes I was tough on the
elite officer it's nothing personal she
really did arrest this man without the
right information and we hope it's a
learning experience that's what life's
about and hopefully uh she gets her uh
cases done differently next time and she
learns some from within the sheriff
learns from this because there's many
mistakes made and if those mistakes
weren't made in this case was done
properly we may not be here but we are
here so let's take this as a learning
experience and we have no hard feelings
towards anyone and we wish everyone the
best and everyone lost in this case no
matter what the verdict is we're all
Losers of the community but we're happy
that the group came out how is Travis
Lawson he lost two years of his life two
years of playing football two years of
uh Roman three two years of hugging his
family two years of having a possible
life sentence hanging over his head
Josh not guilty on all Kells what are
your thoughts
yeah these cases involving self-defense
are always so difficult to to try to
handicap I mean to guess how the jurors
are going to come out on things I find
to be so
um extremely difficult because it it the
cases are supposed to be about an
objective standard it's supposed to be
about how would a reasonable person
behave under the circumstances and is
the responsible reasonable response yet
jurors can't help themselves it's just
like anyone and making this subjective
they put themselves in the position of
the defendant and they ask themselves
what would they do now there was
evidence here that the the the people
who were shot at or retreating that to
me weighs heavily with the prosecution
but then you have the idea that there
was Prior threats the idea that several
people at once showed up and he's only
one person that he's in his own home all
of that plays into the mind of the
defense so my thoughts are you can never
really tell going into these cases how
jurors are going to view it but
obviously in this case and quickly
enough that was most surprising they
came back with a verdict saying that
yeah we do believe that he acted in a
Justified way under the circumstances
okay I want to highlight this real quick
because for Susan Lorenz you said they
should be permit to the murder they did
it here for Rudolph similar situation
seems like you were right but different
different cases I guess but Terry do you
agree on Rudolph's attorney when he said
the prosecution made a mistake or maybe
a flag on the plane when it came to this
case well I definitely think the
prosecution made many mistakes in this
case and you heard the defense attorney
say it right there the investigation was
shoddy the interviews were inadequate
you saw in the body Cam that there were
no follow-up questions when the police
officers were asking about what happened
that night they went to the house there
four of them they went to talk why
didn't they say well what did you go to
talk about were you carrying guns none
of that was done so I do think we could
possibly see in the future maybe claims
for false arrests maybe claims for a
malicious prosecution so we'll see what
happens a lot of people are asking why
that ex-girlfriend isn't facing charges
well we'll see well thank you both and
thank you for joining us here for long
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss Justice in America
foreign
[Music]